on this show I talked about dropping
f-bombs getting clients and why I'm in
such a bad mood i am gary vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching the askgaryvee show
episode 17 little fun fact about the
number 17 is my grandma Esther's and
Xander's birthday the 17th before I get
into the show and start answering these
five great questions to video three
regular I just want to say that I'm an
enormous ly bad mood because the Jets
blew an 18-point lead yesterday
appreciate all of you that were
interacting with me as I was judging
this America yesterday you might have
noticed that my energy level was down my
energy level on this episode will be
down in general as well because I'm
still recovering and one of you huh you
know the hard core of a knee actually
watched Wine Library TV back in the day
remember these kind of Monday episodes
for a lot of you newbies you're not
going to be used to it but you need to
take just like my wine fans did which
was take the scores I gave the wine and
add one or two points because they knew
I was in the depressed narrative you
guys may want to take some of the advice
on this episode as a with a grain of
salt
maybe rocky to put it like a warning
sign here warning warning warning pissed
off and today's answers might be just
okay Darin asks if you could only mark
it on one social platform which would it
be and why Darin I picked this question
because I'm pissed off and I'm pissed
off of people asking this question over
and over again I've been pounding my
fist on the floor or the table over and
over this is a non debate in his
Facebook my friends Facebook's data data
data data data let me say it again as
somebody who doesn't love data who's
more incue than IQ the overwhelming
accuracy of who you are targeting and
the products that they have created to
target those people including in
SUIM not the right side of a website so
I'm over here I like how you're staying
go back there if you're not the right
side of a website but right down the
pipe in the feed targeted properly and
if you're a good enough marketer and
you're putting out content people care
about not an ad and we all see ads know
a piece of content and I know people are
tired of the word content great call
it's stuff I don't give a crap just
something people care about in there
when you know stage show Steve you know
Steve likes Reddit you know Steve likes
back you know Steve likes wine you know
you know he likes these things what else
do you like Steve great what else needs
great so so you know give this man
things of those nuances if you're a
toilet paper
or your toothbrush or a toy company or a
cotton cuff you know what is this
there's a phone you know technology
company like give this man what he wants
around the genres he cares about
Facebook is by far dark posts that's the
terminology unpublished posts the best
platform to be selling things doing
business getting money for your
charities building awareness about your
cause Facebook Facebook this fall my
startup is getting ready to launch its
first product it's an interactive
workshop called the victory rituals
where we flip the morning routine on its
head as we go from concept to final
product what's the best way to empower
our readers to help us spread the word
about victory rituals look forward to
your thoughts
Nicole I like how you positioned that
Nicole how could we empower our readers
to spread the word what you mean is how
do we get our readers that we've been
able to amass to spread the word so we
can get more people into our funnel and
sell this thing which is great because
we're talking about business here two
ways there's only two ways and everybody
saw a lovely Nicole asked the question
and she was very politically correct in
my opinion and structuring it properly
but what you're basically saying is I
have a massive audience and now I want
to sell them stuff and not only do I
want to sell
stuff because I feel like I'm entitled
to because I've given them a bunch of
free content on email over the course of
these last couple of months or a year
Nicole huh how you've been doing it plus
but I also want them to not only buy but
then I also want them to spread the word
so other people buy there's only two
ways to have the audacity to make that
ask and that's what that is my friends
you can be doing a daily email and
putting out great content you could be
putting out a great show every day but
then you come to that moment a book or
something and there's only two ways to
convert number one write a good book in
your case Nicole your product needs to
be good is it worth the $38 is it worth
the 83 dollars is it worth the three
hundred eighty eight dollars is it worth
the $883 I used to be mates in there if
anybody was paying attention so first
and foremost the best way to convert and
empower them
aka have them push it on to others is by
putting out something great that they
want to tell other people to use they
valued it more than they paid for it
number two is good old-fashioned honesty
you just need to be really upfront with
them of what you want from them you want
them to share your video you want them
to go to your website you need to be
upfront with the fact that here are the
things that you want and so for me it's
putting out a great product that's worth
the money and number two not hedging
your right hook just asking for it like
a woman Dan asked what's your process
for vetting the clients specifically at
vaynermedia
Dan answer number one do you have enough
money Dan answer number two what I'm
really looking for to not make a joke
and he's just putting me in a better
mood guys I gotta be honest with you I
forgot that that's what Wine Library TV
did for me on these Mondays where I want
to annihilate people's souls putting out
a show with my community does help my
field I need a lot of comments on this
episode by the way I need comments in
there I need I need comments anyway you
know the the things we're looking out
for is are they creative the number one
thing I'm scared of is we
of creativity and we can do real work
but if people want to follow a very
strict process of how they've always
done it versus how we're supposed to do
it I'm petrified in that and so really
there's no way to do it cuz everybody
says they want to be innovative and due
to the new thing and invest in the
future and then you get into
practicality the first thing that's cut
is the future which is why so many
people lose so everybody's into defense
versus offense when times get tough for
me when times get tough you go harder
not in any way so I'm trying to sniff
out if people have the stomach to be
innovative and do things differently to
take some risks but be practical but
have a little more patience for that
practicality and that ROI itself Bryan
has this CEO of an up-and-coming IPO
company I'm very impressed with your
audacity to ask that question which
leads to my very simple answer which is
twofold I think the reason I get away
with dropping the f-bomb is number one I
mean it when I say it there's no tactic
I'm just in the zone I mean I was
inspired by Richard Pryor and Chris Rock
and Eddie Murphy and their styles have
translated to my keynote styles I feel
like I do a little bit of a stand-up
timing process and I think that because
I'm not forcing it and because it's my
Naturals own little Jersey boy action
people respect authenticity the other
reason I'm able to get away with it is I
don't care if I receive flak as a matter
of fact I use the f-bomb to vet people
let me you know obscenity before I'm
gonna say it again we're gonna do it
again the question coming up this is a
platform for me for the hardcore last
seven years fans of mine for me to go
one layer deeper into things I've never
said before the truth is I actually use
my f-bomb to vet other people I actually
react to the way you're reacting to my
f-bomb because if you are a person back
to the last question that is so thrown
off by using the f-bomb in public in a
public setting
with a keynote that you're then not
looking at big enough picture for me
just my person you're judging me I'm
judging you so if you are incapable of
getting over that and seeing the bigger
statement that I'm creating well then
you're gonna be somebody that I want to
do business with invest in or take on as
a client to begin with because you're at
this micro level that's right you're at
this micro level and that's just not a
place where I want to play I don't want
to play in the micro so [ __ ] you Seth
asked what was the hardest thing when
starting out vaynermedia from scratch
Seth you know this is another place for
me to give a little bit of insight
believe it or not yes not doing wine
library day-to-day with my dad yes the
notion of taking the risk of being and
another family business and not ruining
the relationship with AJ confident on
both fronts the hardest thing was
actually being crippled by options the
notion that over the first nine months
it was very difficult for me not to
think about the fact that me and AJ had
800 other things we could have done and
did we pick the right thing I think a
lot of people who were watching this are
always crippled I get this a ton which
is why I picked this question why didn't
pick it
you know Steve we picked weekend you
know how did we pick it there's a little
collaborative right you trying to give
me a different question I said no no I
like this one because it allows me to
give an answer to my audience that I see
a lot of you struggling with it's been
asked of me a ton on email Twitter and
other places which is at some point
you've got to put your big-boy pants on
and say I've made this decision and you
move on the buyers regret or remorse or
like did I do the right thing or
crippled by options is something so many
of you are struggling with and I
struggled with it as well especially
with all the opportunities that I've
been able to be given I'm so fortunate
that I'm struggling with like should I
do a national TV show should I should I
extend the fund by 10 times and do a
quarter billion dollar fund
quadruple down on vain you know I'm
crippled I'm crippled by options which
is a blessing and a half and so the
hardest thing was in 2009 was like is
this the right thing
don't forget fingers started known I may
have oh nine Misha was born in May of oh
nine and crush it came out in October of
oh nine so there was all those other
things going on
I was the struggle the hardest thing was
not starting the business it was second
guessing was was it the right use of my
time and AJ's time and upside and
talents at the time and that's it a
pissed still I hate Packer nation for a
week because I actually don't have a
problem because we don't play each other
again for four years and the last time
we were Lambo we won thirty five to
seven and that felt good but that was
last time and I know you're gonna say
what happened this time and what
happened this time was a lot of
misfortune of things which is fortunate
things that really really hurt my soul
and my feelings and I'm in a state of
sadness for the rest of today and
probably into tomorrow but by Wednesday
I'll start gathering the momentum to
start focusing on the Bears and Monday
night and I'll be there at the game on
Monday night you keep asking questions
I'll keep trying to answer oh right
question of the day I don't know just
tell me about yourself in the comments I
just want to read a lot of comments from
my community and feel better so tell me
something good and that's just not a
place where I want to play I don't want
to play in the micro so [ __ ] you